[Music]
I want to let my head down while staring
down your face. Want to go till lights
out. Yeah. Take a right back to my
place. You watch your mind.
If you don't know what this is, I tell
them one by one. One by one. Twist my
wrist. Pause like this. Start with a
track. Eyes on me. Watch your back just
like this. Here for the night. We're
burning. Just keep watching. Like this.
Back eyes on me. How you like that? Just
like this.
Just keep watching.
[Music]
I want to make my mind up. Don't know
where this might go. Want to take your
time off.
But you make it diffic they try but they
don't know what this is. So tell them
one by one by one. Twist my wrists like
this. Start with the track. Eyes on me.
My back just like this night. Just keep
watching. Like this back on me like
that. Just like this.
Just keep watching.
[Music]
It's all right. If you can't keep up me,
I can love
all.
It's all right. If you take it, we can
love.
All night
just like this.
Just keep watching like this back.
Just keep watching.
[Music]
Hey there friends. I hope you enjoyed
that flow session back in the dance
studio as much as I enjoyed making it.
Real quickly, uh, if you want to get a
hold of a set of those LED contact po,
the Orb Poy pros that I was using in
this video, you can get 10% off on them
when you use the code Drex Factor with a
zero instead of an O at checkout over at
ultrao.com. Thank you so much to Ultraoy
for sponsoring this video. And speaking
of thank yous, I owe thanks to the
friends of the channel. Big thanks to
Dark Monk, Fire Mecca, Flowfests, Flow
Toys, Pyroer, Light Toys, and Ultraoy
for helping to make the videos on this
channel possible. You can learn more
about all these awesome companies and
the work they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links down in the description of
this video. And special thanks to the
non-b businessiness friend of the
channel, Becca Beckman. Thank you so
much for supporting my channel, my work,
and my mission. And of course, this
video and all the videos on this channel
would not be possible without my amazing
supporters on Patreon. In particular,
I'd love to give a huge shout out to my
Flo patrons who are listed on screen
right now. Thank you so much. You all
rock. And if you would like to get your
name in the credits or access to a host
of other awesome rewards, you can go
sign up for my Patreon over at
patreon.com/drexfactorpo.
I'll include the link to it down in the
description as well as up in the cards.
But for now, thank you so much for
watching. And if you'd like to check out
more videos of me doing flow sessions
like this one, I'll include a link to a
playlist of them down in the description
as well as up on screen. Take care now
and make sure you get out and flow
yourself today. Peace.